[Applause]
so
uh
oh
[Applause]
the basket by the phone
can you not move my stuff please i have
it all where it is so i know where it is
sorry yeah
i was just trying to give us more space
you know i'm gonna move out as soon as i
can
jules i didn't say anything about moving
out
i'm sorry i'm just getting ready to go
evict
another family with kids
give them 10 15 minutes to grab what
they can carry throw it in their car if
they have a car and then
i wish you wouldn't have run paul you
didn't have to
there weren't exactly too many people
banging down the doors for the position
after warren stokes retired
i barely recognize this place anymore
yeah well a lot can change in 20 years
it's our own
little slice of paradise here
who's next
lucas
you want to read us your story you can't
read miss meadows i see ken
i know you've been working on a story
will you read us a little bit
once
there were three bears
that lived in a dark and wet cave
up above a small town
big bear
little bear and baby bear
big bear
you should take care of the little bears
but big bear got sick
lost his job
and his insides turned black
one day
little bear came home
and big bear and baby bear were
different
big bear's sickness had gotten worse
big bear
has become more angrier
and meaner
because they had no food
no meat
it's
very good lucas
but they had each other
oh my god is that dog [ __ ] god dude that
smells like ass
dude
you [ __ ] you think this is funny
does that hurt
okay
okay you put your shirt back on
we'll be right out
it's not working
so
um
see what happens next order the entire
movie
antlers
now available
you